Every time you drive through
a signalized intersection,
the traffic signals change
state-- and red, yellow, green.
And it operates, and it's
all kind of magic, right?
It's not really magic.
Every intersection has
one of these cabinets.
And so, let me show you
what's in the cabinet.
25 years ago, I
was asked to work
on a real-time adaptive
signal control project.
And at that time, I was
doing nonlinear differential
equations for monitoring
patients in anesthesia.
And I thought, traffic?
That's red, yellow, green.
That's easy.
I can do that.
I wonder what I'll do
after the summer's over.
That was 25 years ago.
This is the real brain.
It's called the
signal controller.
And this is what's responsible
for timing the different phases
of the traffic signal.
In the road are loops of wire.
And that's what used to
detect vehicles as they
flow among the intersection.
But that's only right here, 60
foot from the stop bar, right?
And so, what we do is we use
connected vehicle technology
to talk to the vehicles.
So on top of the signal
out here is a radio,
and that allows us to have
conversations with vehicles.
This project is a
collaboration of the University
of Arizona, ADOT, and Maricopa
County working together.
You know, if we can save even
two seconds to a fire truck--
to the emergency vehicle that
is responding to somebody
having a heart
attack, it can make
a difference of life and death.
So obviously, the
public is paying for it.
But if you look at
the cost benefit,
I mean, to compare the cost of
one radio, which is currently
about $2,400 to
value of saving life?
I mean, if we can reduce
fatalities by 80%,
that's a huge benefit
to the public.
Transit One is en route now.
So what happens is, when
the intersection receives
the request for
priority-- from one,
two, three, four-- however
many vehicles are asking
for priority, the
research that we've done
is to focus on those requests,
the structure of the traffic
control at the intersection,
and how we can optimally
solve a timing problem to
allow the vehicles to go
through the intersection
in the most efficient way?
Signals didn't talk to each
other in the beginning.
We made them talk to
each other, right?
Now cars are talking to signals.
And now we're able to
really do something.
And I love it because we
can make a difference.
We can make a difference
in people's lives every day
by making it safer, making
it more efficient for them
to drive.